[Music]
I'm Butler Lampson and Barbara has asked
me to introduce Jim this is Jim Gray
currently a colleague of mine at
Microsoft Jim and I have go back a long
way because we were both students at
Berkeley in the late 60s
since then Jim has worked at a variety
of industrial labs IBM tandem digital
equipment and recently Microsoft and he
is one of the pioneers of the database
and transaction processing business and
indeed laid many of the conceptual
foundations for transaction processing
that we all depend on today to get our
bank statements and our airline
reservations and all kinds of other
things to work right I remember a few
years ago I got a whole series of bank
statements that had entries of the form
September 15 $400 taken out of the ATM
machine September 15 $400 taken out of
the ATM machine
September 17th canceling the second
hundred-dollar withdrawal from the Jim
Messina machine so clearly that was a
case worth at the non transaction
processing system hadn't done the right
thing and some person came along
afterwards and said oh yeah that I
recognized that if that mistake undid it
by hand so transaction processing is
really wonderful stuff in fact it took
me many years to even though I worked on
some of it more or less in parallel with
Jim it took me many years to realize how
wonderful it is it's it's this pixie
dust that you can sprinkle on on
programs you you have a completely
boring run-of-the-mill sequential non
fault tolerant program written by some
random application programmer and you
sprinkled TP dust on it and it magically
becomes concurrent it magically becomes
fault-tolerant magically it gets
automatically scheduled and load
balanced and everything you could
possibly wish for and it's the only
thing like this that we know how to do
in computing if any of you can figure
out another thing like that that we
do another kind of Pixy dust that we
could sprinkle on programs that would be
a fabulous achievement anyway in recent
years
transaction processing is more or less
solve Gemma has moved on to other
aspects of computing having to do with
large quantities of data a few years ago
he built a system called the Terra
server which you can find on the web at
Terra calm right Terra server com Terra
service that Renaud service as opposed
to server because it's a web service it
also does the old stuff but it doesn't a
lot of good new stuff too it has a huge
collection of satellite images of the
world and you can zero in on your very
own house or what it's the resolution
it's good enough that you can sort of
see a blurry thing that corresponds to a
car right it's one meter so small car
it's blurry you have an American car
it's more than OB several meters and
today he's going to talk to us about the
next giant a real world database project
which is astronomy so the database
community has been as Mike Stonebreaker
says polishing a round ball for many
many years we've been making we've been
doing the same stuff we used to do
better and the advice that the database
community keeps giving itself is to
invest in application areas broaden the
database agenda to handle text broaden
the database agenda to handle a
geospatial broad in the database agenda
to handle image data and also broaden it
to do data analysis data mining and
incidentally data visualization and I've
been trying to take that advice and to
go into application areas and hope that
the application areas will suggest
interesting research problems for the
database community and for myself in
particular and this is a story of what
I've been doing for the last two years
working primarily with the Astronomy
community
and trying to build what we sometimes
called the worldwide telescope or the
virtual observatory and the idea is to
try and take the astronomy archives that
are exist in the ones that are coming
and make them a federated database which
then is accessible to everybody
everywhere and in this in this new world
the best telescope in the world is the
internet so that's the top level a story
in doing this I found myself working
with quite a few people I work with the
people at Johns Hopkins we're quite
closely we correspond daily basically
particular Alex Sally
Peter kunst is now at CERN honey Thacker
is still back at Johns Hopkins and also
to federated database you have to have
two databases to federates so I've had
to try and find somebody else who has
some data and it turns out that the
people at Caltech have both the Palomar
Observatory and the Keck Observatory and
they have lots and lots of data from
both of those telescopes and so I've
been working with them to get their data
online and now we're in right in the
throes of federating those two databases
so this is very much a work in progress
so what I'm going to do is first talk to
you about astronomy data then I'm going
to talk to you about the virtual
observatory and then talk in detail
about the Sloan Sky Survey I'm giving a
talk tomorrow that dovetails with this
one that is much more detailed about
database aspects it's going to slight
the first two parts of this talk and
focus much more on the third part so at
the top level and what I think is really
going on here is that there's
theoretical and empirical science and
then there's typically a tension between
theoreticians and empiricists in the
last 50 years there's been a new kind of
science that's become increasingly
popular and influential and that's
computational science but most of
computational science over the last 50
years has been simulations people build
an analytic model of some physical
system and they simulate it and they try
and understand the science associated
with
Kanaka system or a physical system or a
biological system by simulating it and
use that as a way of building a
scientific theory something that is
happening increasingly now and it's been
going on really for the last 15 years
but we are at least in astronomy at a
cusp right now is that in the old days
people would go to telescope and look
through the telescope and write down
what they saw and then they would would
cameras came along they would take a
camera and and put it the other end of
the telescope and then they'd look at
the film and but fundamentally it was
humans looking at data and people would
do most of the data analysis and in this
new world there's a scientific
instrument be it the accelerator at CERN
or be it the telescope in that I'm the
people that i've been working with are
using in new mexico and that device
collects lots of data and it's basic
unit of data is a terabyte and which is
to say a million megabytes and it takes
that data and it sends it off to a data
pipeline and the data pipeline takes
that data and processes it and turns it
into in the case of nuclear physics
events and in the case of astronomy
objects in spectra and those objects in
spectra go on to a disk and at some
later time the astronomer comes along
and looks at those objects in spectra
and treats the collection of all the
objects in the collection of all the
spectra as a corpus and they do analysis
on that corpus sometimes looking for odd
things sometimes looking for trends and
this is a different kind of Sciences
computational science but it's data
mining rather than simulation you have
in essence the universe is your
simulator and you're getting the data
out and there's a lot of it and there's
so much of it that you no human being
can look at it you need a robot to
analyze the data
so the astronomers fundamentally like
many Sciences are writing Moore's law so
the picture at the bottom the is the CCD
chart this is optical Astronomy Picture
of the bottom is the number of pixels or
in fact I think is it megapixels the
number of megapixels that the
astronomers have that's hiding behind
some large telescope the picture the
graph at the top is the number of square
meters of telescope so the picture at
the top is how many photons they've got
to work with
that's the aperture in the picture at
the bottom is how efficient they are at
harvesting those photons and and the
CCDs are getting better and better and
better right now the astronomers have
about a gigapixel right now the
astronomers are building a single
telescope that it has a gigapixel ccd so
what's fundamentally going on is that
every two years they double the amount
of data that they've captured right now
they have a few petabytes probably one
petabyte of good data and a few
petabytes of data of unknown provenance
--is what we might call it the if you
just take a picture of the sky with one
pixel per square arc second you get
about four terabytes and that's the kind
of resolution that these telescopes have
so your basic data set is four terabytes
and it you can but you can take pictures
in multiple parts of the spectrum and
you can take pictures at multiple times
and so an interesting thing about
astronomy data which is a little bit
different from say nuclear physics data
is physics doesn't change much from day
to day the Higgs particle is the same
today as it was yesterday to a first
approximation stars and galaxies do
change they they have a strong temporal
dimension and they also have a strong
spectral dimension and I'll show some
examples of that in a while
so what the astronomers do with this
data is they mine it and there's sort of
two kinds of things there's what I'll
call the easy problems which is looking
for strange objects
look for high-redshift things that you
know look like there might be quasars
and then you go off and look at those
things in detail or look for very cold
things and those are brown dwarfs things
that are much bigger than the planets
but a lot smaller than the Sun and so
they aren't thermonuclear they're just
giving off heat because of the
gravitational force so these are kinds
of objects that ten or fifteen years ago
were not very well understood and now
there's we have lots of examples of them
and we're beginning to be able to
characterize them much better as I said
the data doubles every two years
astronomy community unlike some other
communities and and they share their
data and if if you go to Walmart and ask
Walmart to share their data they will
say no if you go to Yahoo or or
Microsoft and say share your data
they'll say no so you can get terabytes
from lots of places in theory but in
practice you can't if you go to medical
imaging and want to get a bunch of
x-rays you might be able to get that
information but there's all sorts of
privacy concerns an interesting thing
about the astronomy data is it's
completely worthless there's no
commercial value associated with
astronomy data okay so in fact we've
done stuff of Earth Observation and and
pictures of your backyard turns out that
has commercial value and there's all
sorts of stuff of stepping on people's
toes because you're publishing something
that for free that they could sell so
one interesting thing about the
astronomy data is there's lots of it it
has interesting dimensions temporal
spectral and others and it's free and
the astronomers have a history of
sharing and of publishing their data and
these things it's I've actually looked
hard for data like this and it's not
trivial to find it this is actually one
of the best examples I found so if you
do the math interesting thing about
doubling times is that what happens in
the next doubling time equals what
happened in history of mankind okay so
the area under the curve in the next two
years equals the area under the curve
although integrated back to zero t
equals zero so the amount of data that
the
again next year or next two years is
equal to the amount of data that they
got in the history of mankind
the next petabyte but the old petabyte
is public so there are people who act
have access to the old petabyte and
maybe 10% of the new petabyte and then
everybody has access to the old petabyte
so some people have 55% access and some
people have 50% access so this is a huge
democratizing influence in astronomy
people in Africa can get to this data
people in Asia can get to this data and
of course people at caltech can get to
the data the people that Caltech and
Johns Hopkins have 55% in the people
everywhere else have 50% but just
exactly how do I get to that 50% the
astronomers do have a culture of
publishing they have this format called
fits files so you know fundamentally you
can go to one of these archives and you
can say I'd like to download the archive
and of course get started you know if
you're in Africa and you have a phone
line voice grade
don't try and download a petabyte to it
and once you've got it where are you
going to put it but probably more
troubling than that is that the details
of publishing are really hard there's a
book by Douglas Adams called The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and the
the theme of that book it has several
themes but boil down to a simple
one-liner answers forty-two so all of
astronomy can be summarized and in fact
all of existence can be summarized that
way so you know no the problem is you
have to ask Adams so what are the units
on that okay and what is the precision
on that what is the error bar is it 42
plus or minus 1 or 42 plus or minus 10
okay
and and and exactly how did you come to
that conclusion it turns out that when
somebody gives you some data you would
like to know all the processing steps
that went through because I mean it's
really a really interesting thing about
that is that he was able to reduce all
of human existence in some algorithmic
way to this number 42 and I'd like to
him to show his work
is what the you know typical high school
teacher would tell you know given the
answer and show your work right so and I
actually read that book and it doesn't
actually explain how look it doesn't
explain so-so
and I claimed that it would be rather
fairly he's dead now but it would if
he'd stuck around it would have been
rather difficult for him to show his
work okay and you know if you want to
explain very briefly to somebody who's
not practically you know experienced in
the art just talk to them about you know
forty two is the answer okay now you
know what was the question and what are
the units and what's the precision and
and in fact what was the process and
then there are a few other details like
the astronomers typically don't have a
petabyte so you really need to leave the
data where it came from the data
actually is best understood by the
people who gathered it and who are
publishing it and in fact you typically
publish the data and algorithms to mess
around with the data so my premise is
that what we are really want to do is to
have a set of archives and each archive
manages the data that it collected so if
you have a radio telescope you also have
a radio telescope archive if you have
the Space Telescope the Hubble Space
Telescope then you have the Hubble Space
Telescope archive if you did the Sloan
Sky Survey then you have the Sloan Sky
Survey archive and now consumers of this
data want to go and treat all of these
archives as a homogeneous set of data
and ask questions of it so the there are
plumbing problems let me call them
database problems about well how do you
manage a petabyte and how do you load a
petabyte and how you index it and so on
but I think the really challenging
problems is how do we make it easy for
people to publish information because
frankly the astronomers want to do
astronomy they don't want to become
publishers of astronomy data they want
to pay publishers of astronomy results
and how do once it's published how do we
make it easy for the consumers to go and
ask questions of the data and get
answers back so just the characteristics
there's lots of it
it's high dimensional and cross
correlation is challenging because
it's multi-resolution it's time varying
and the data is very dirty an airplane
flies in front of your favorite object
and it's sometimes they've noticed that
it's an airplane and the object is bad
in their thing and sometimes they have a
hard time disambiguating the airplane
from the object or cosmic rays or so
here's I'm just gonna try and get across
the time dimension so if you were an
astronomer a thousand years ago and you
looked up in the sky at really good eyes
you would have seen a little white dot
and it's what's called the crab star and
and now this is the way it looks this is
the same object being observed in the
radio the optical the infrared and the
x-ray bands and they look completely
different
at least they look completely different
to me and each of those pictures gives
you a different structural description
of the object so this is this is both
showing you the fact that it's very
important to be able to look in multiple
spectra
multiple spectral bands and incidentally
all this false-color here say in the
upper right is really due to the fact
that they're observing it in four or
five color bands and the optical and
then they're making a coffee-table image
of this thing but there's actually five
different pictures that are being melded
together there and each of the five
pictures look different in fact this is
trying to get across that idea though
let's see if I can use this a wonderful
thing okay so here's a very very nice
spiral galaxy okay which is just a speck
in that spectrum band but it's but it's
actually very clear here and what's
likely is this is shifted way down so
this is probably a very highly
redshifted yeah galaxy it's my guess and
but these objects all look different in
the different bands okay so you're what
you've got is a bunch of different
observations and you're trying to
understand whether it's the same object
and objects vary over time and I showed
you the the the Crab Nebula car the star
varying over time
so here's the the basic mathematical
problem that we're up against somebody
gives you a bunch of data okay and
that's this picture up at the top and
you would like to break that data into
clusters and you know the way we are
approaching the data today and the way
the astronomers have approached the data
historically is in the old days they
used did it by hand and increasingly
they used computers and more and more
and more they're using data mining
algorithms and clustering algorithms and
much better algorithms but still it's
manual Drive okay so what would be
really nice is to have automatic
transmission which is to say you pour
the data into the database and it
wanders over it because people are the
way they do these analysis is they
operate in two dimensions and they plot
things and if you go into an astronomers
office the wall is covered with 2d plots
and if you go and look on their desktop
in their computer it's covered with
window after window after window of the
same data plotted X versus Y Y versus Z
X versus Z and so on and and
convolutions of XY and z so what would
be nice is if you could give a data set
to the computer and it could go and try
to do all that for you and incidentally
the processing element in all of this is
then the human eye looking for either a
straight line or some trend line it
would be nice if you could get the
computer to do that for you really fast
ok and and would even be nicer I'm sure
it's gonna have some false positives but
it would be nice if some of the things
that suggested were useful things that
people haven't observed and one of the
things you'll notice right away about
what I said is that the astronomers are
now very good at finding 2d correlations
but they're not especially good at
finding three and four and 5d
correlations it happens but that the
methods I described don't really show
that
so here's the premise of the virtual
observatory most of the data will be
online so the world's best telescope is
the Internet
okay the nice thing about the Internet
is has data on every part of the sky
okay
it has data in all the measured spectra
the data is as good as the best
instrument two years ago because I said
the reason the data isn't public
immediately is that the astronomers
typically work a decade to build their
instrument so they they would like to
have first shot at the resulting data
okay
that's hard for me as a computer guy to
imagine starting a project where I'm not
going to get my first result for 10
years or 15 years and I'm gonna have to
sync 100 million dollars into it but in
fact I just was flying visiting people
at CERN they're gonna be about 10
billion dollars in the hole before they
get their first event out and the
official story is it's going to take
them 10 years but it's probably gonna
take him 15 years before they get
started so it's it's this is this is big
science ok but the Internet is little
science ok which is to say you can pull
out the data that interests you and
process it on a fairly modest computer
the nice thing about the Internet is
it's up when you're up ok astronomers
have this tradition of you go to the
telescope it's some night maybe you get
two or three nights of observation and
incidentally if it's cloudy that night
you're out of luck okay so people fly to
Hawaii and and sit there and deal with
the Keck and if there's a storm going by
then they're there they get to vacation
and talk to be chilling and the other
thing is that it's a smart telescope
which is to say you can point to an
object and get all the information about
that object not just from that
observatory but from all the other
observatories and also get the
literature on that object and get the
literature on all the other objects or
that are like that object
so I'm gonna be talking about the Sloane
but the astronomers as I said are on
Moore's law and they're doing lots and
lots of these broad spectrum of A's you
know typically each survey is at a
different part of the spectrum and about
25% of their budget is software which is
I found an interesting fact about 25% of
their budget goes into building the data
pipeline to do the data analysis and
data publication is an integral part of
the surveys the I said that they had
about a petabyte of data and they have
many more petabytes of unknown
provenance even that petabyte that is of
known provenance much of it is is is a
little rough hasn't been gathered in a
in a systematic way it was it was a
particular part of the sky and they
point a telescope here and then they
pointed to telescope here and then they
pointed to telescope here so it's not
necessarily a good statistical sample so
federating these new surveys is a real
challenge and if you have a pretty good
chance of doing Federation because these
surveys many of them are just getting
started and they're building the
software right now so we have some
influence on what they're going to build
and how they're going to publish their
data and the challenges of course well
it's petabytes and that's still a lot of
bytes
there's the unsolved metadata problem
there's the fact that the current
visualization and data analysis tools
are inadequate and there's the fact that
it's hard to get a job in an astronomy
department or in a computer science
department if you work in this area
because this is a not well established
field in either astronomy or computer
science so the approach fortunately I
don't have to get tenure so I'm I'm I
get to more or less spend some of my
time doing what I want to do and so I
have sort of have this three-step
program of first trying to get to
surveys online and up as a web service
and then Fedder 8 to 2 of them together
and you know in that Federation is going
to require some agreement between
Caltech and Johns Hopkins about
what kind of units they're going to
externalise I'll talk about that in a
minute so like I can't give you a demo
of the virtual sky stuff but there's the
URL for it and what what the what the
virtual sky is it's all of the Palomar
data pour it into something that's very
much like the Terra server except
looking the other way okay and so you
can pan across the sky and you can point
to an object and drill down and drill
down and drill down and in a certain
point you can say go off and show me the
pictures you have from the other Palomar
datasets and they have three or four
data sets or go off to Ned which is the
database of literature about astronomy
and there's another database called
Vizier and Sinbad that's in in France in
Grenoble and these so these there's a
cross correlation between the objects
you're looking at and the literature
about objects and for famous objects you
get lots of hits and for you know an
object that is you know very very faint
you're likely to get nothing in the
database but we could say recognize that
object and say oh that's a galaxy of
this class and here's all the literature
for the most common literature about
galaxies of that type okay so I can give
you a demo of this guy and I hope yes I
can I bet so
so I have a 1% subset of the Sloane data
on my laptop here and I have a little
web server that goes along with it and
here's the front page of the of the sky
server and and it has some interesting
components to it it was originally done
as a so-called outreach project it was
originally done to make the NSF happy
that the this the Sloane astronomers are
helping K through 12 ok which turns out
to be an important thing for the
National Science Foundation teach
science to K through 12 so there is a
whole bunch of things here about and
this is a subset of this about teaching
people about the Hubble diagram or
teaching people about redshifts or
teaching people about spectra and so
they're a bunch of classes and this is
actually very participatory these
classes are typically 15 hours and at
the end of the 15 hours you've
discovered the Hubble diagram or you've
discovered redshifts and you've also
learned to do data analysis complete
with an understanding of error bars and
the fact that scientific data sometimes
gives you false answers and things like
that so there are things for young young
kids which are Easter egg hunts and
there are things for middle school kids
which are you know really basic science
teaching some mathematics and then there
are things which teach broader more
advanced topics for the astronomers well
actually what's my favorite place is
famous places and this is all you know
just things from the photo gallery this
is a coffee table and you can point to
one of these things and you know and
those are two galaxies that are
interacting so this is stuff that's just
you know from from the database things
that were found that we're interesting
but you can also go to this thing and
get information about the objects in a
certain part of the sky so now we're
actually going off to the database
okay and those are that's the summary
information about all the objects in a
certain neighborhood and you can type in
a latitude or XR right Ascension and
declination and a radius or a bounding
box and get information about these
things and you can get more information
incidentally the scary thing is that's
the sequel and we're trying to teach
people sequel which is probably a stupid
thing to try and do like teaching a pig
to sing I think and and I mean we ought
to teach people better tools than that
but you can have you can actually type
in raw sequel what else don't not proud
of that
okay and but you can do it and it says
not for the faint of heart
but we are working on a on a on a GUI
interface where you you show people the
database schema and they point and click
and the joins are done for them and and
simple kinds of queries can be done that
way and we're working on trying to make
more complicated words with so this is
the Terra server kind of approach where
you can point to a spot in the sky and
now that's the blow-up of that spot in
the sky and you can point to that spot
and there's the detailed information
about that spot or the summary
information and it's it's that's the
point in the sky it's a galaxy its 19th
magnitude in the green and sixteen in
the red and here is the detailed
information from the database about that
thing it's I said it was high
dimensional data there's like 400
attributes associated with that thing
okay and I guess I didn't show the
spectra and I should show that and then
I'll get on with the end of demo get
images I think it's called spectra and
actually plates is it is a good thing to
do
so these the way they take spectra they
take them 600 at a time there's about
50,000 spectra in this thing when
they're done they'll have a million
spectra and you can point to that this
is this this layout just says these are
all the spectra that we're taking at one
instant and we have a qso with a
redshift of 2 and there's its spectra
and it doesn't look very good because
the browser is messing it up but there's
the spectrogram associated with it and
incidentally there's a whole bunch of
data associated with the spectrogram
it's been processed and they've
extracted there's typically about 30
spectral lines in a database and now you
can ask questions about the spectral
lines and the spectrogram but this is
the this is the picture associated with
it much as you'd have a picture
associated with a galaxy or a star so
that guy exists he's he's running along
he's being used by people as I said it
was intended primarily as something for
K through 12 what we're actually finding
is that the astronomers have such crappy
tools that they also find this pretty
useful and if K through 12 can actually
get to use this than the astronomers can
actually figure out how this interface
works as well okay and so we're
beginning to have people come to this
and starting to do science on this
interface and as a consequence we're
making it more elaborate okay so I I've
talked a little bit about this but
there's this notion that the virtual
Observatory could actually have a
substantial impact on education and I
think I mentioned that you know in the
beginning in science was empirical and
then we began to have an analytic
science and now we're heading into this
era of computational science which is
traditionally meant simulation I don't
mean that simulation is going away but
there's a second branch of computational
science which is data analysis and I
think that is increasing data mining and
so on and this is this is a very good
place to teach data mining so here is a
data set it's public you can actually
get a tiny version of it on your laptop
you could put this in schools and you
could teach people how to do data
analysis
with this and in fact in fact that is
being done so it's actually a nice way
of teaching astronomy you can talk to
people about a certain kind of
astronomical phenomena and then you can
go off and have them either discover it
or explore it so what next well after
we've got the data online and after the
web servers are serving up those HTML
pages and I guess I didn't show but the
I could have clicked if I'd done the
sequel and got an XML out so it'll
produce XML or HTML or comma-separated
lists and we're working on having it
produce fits files which are the lingua
franca for the astronomers so what how
do you actually publish the data so one
answer is oh well you just publish XML
and perhaps you publish a schema and
you're and you're done and the problem
is that bytes are the wrong abstraction
Barbara's here you folks have been
leading the OO charge for many many many
many many many years I forget who it was
but somebody said algorithms are
programs plus data was it worth that
yeah so you know XML is just data it's
no programs okay so you need to have
when you publish you need to publish
programs plus data now you don't
actually sort publish the source code
your programs you publish the methods
okay how to call the program okay so we
are struggling with the following
challenge what are the objects in
astronomy I mean you look up in the sky
and you see specks of light you know and
and but the astronomers have a much
fancier categorization than just you
know the color of the thing so what are
they what are the objects what are the
methods on those objects what attributes
do the objects have now clearly we don't
know every day people find new
attributes for the objects people find
that new things are important okay so
you've whatever you decide you're wrong
okay but there are a few things that we
know the objects have a position in
space as of
certain time and they have a velocity in
space and some of the objects we can
measure the velocity so there's some
stuff in 3-space there's in a particular
spectral band there's something that you
measure and you can and of course
everything is measured at an instant in
time or a period in time so there are a
whole bunch of parameters that are sort
of standard that the astronomers can
measure so we're trying to come up with
essentially what are the basic things
that are known about objects that
everybody can agree to and then an
escape mechanism which in fact is XML to
let people describe everything else the
in fact the terror server is a example
of this what we have done for the Terra
server has turned it from a web server
which serves up HTML pages to a web
service which answers our pcs so if you
go to tera service.com
and you just type that what you'll get
back is a bunch of XML that describes
the methods it supports and that's the
web service definition language coming
back at you so this is it'll for the
internet interface definition language
and if you go to uddi or disco or
something you can discover the terrorist
service and discover that it's a
geospatial server but what that stuff
that comes back to you is a list of all
the methods you can do and there's a
schema that's referenced in those
methods that say ok I returned place
names and I returned I returned images
of spatial rectangles and and so on
and all of the notions of what is a
place name and what is a spatial
rectangle and so on are defined in a
schema again a piece of XML ok so now
you can go and say in your program knew
of Terror service you know have a handle
you can now call a method that says give
me a picture of my house ok which is a
bounding box is this is the upper
left-hand corner this is the lower
right-hand corner in latitude and
longitude and the next thing you know in
your address space
is a bitmap of an aerial photo of your
house and what's happened is an RPC has
gone off to this thing it's been
marshaled into XML go on across the
internet unmarshal at the other end
turned into a real RPC littered around
in the database come back stitch
together at the image that you asked for
take that image marshal it into XML send
it back to your program unmarshal to
back into your address space okay just
standard RPC and if you want you can say
no I don't want it I'd want to see the
XML I don't want to see it in Java you
know classes or I don't want to see it
in in c structs I want to see it in in
in its original form which is the raw
XML okay so the terra servus is worth
looking at and we're trying to do the
same thing for astronomy archives and so
you basically say give me a new handle
on the sky server and then you the sky
server has a method called get objects
and that method returns a whole bunch of
attributes okay and now you've got those
attributes in your address space and you
can do whatever you want with them and
so and the thing we're struggling with
in fact is how much of this can we do is
early binding and how much of it is late
binding which is to say to what extent
do we return XML documents and to what
extent do we return Java classes or cc I
mean the things that you know about it
compile time
so now I'm going to segue to a little
bit of discussion about the the Sloane
itself and what I've been doing with
that data again these guys have been
building instrument for about 12 years
last year they gathered a bunch of data
they have about three terabytes of raw
data and about 50 gigabytes of cooked
data and when I say cook data these are
15 million objects and lots of
attributes associated with the objects
so that little disk drive there has is
60 gigabytes so it easy it's actually 80
gigabytes it easily holds all the data
and this is not the image data and the
raw data this is the processed data it
has all the spectral images but it
doesn't have all of the cutouts of the
various galaxies and stars so I've been
working on making it easy for
astronomers to access this data and the
way they access it today is it's ASCII
files and there are C programmers and
they write C modules and they write
tickle scripts that invoke those C
modules and they go and paw over all the
files and look for interesting things or
look for trends okay and the premise is
you could take all the stuff that's in
those C files throw it into a database
index the heck out of it and then write
queries against the data okay so I've
been trying to do that and the question
is well what kind of questions do the
astronomers ask so Alex Haley gave me a
list of 20 questions and this is a
characteristic of the kind of question
and surah number would want to ask of
the data would take about a week to
write the C program and run it and get
the answer out do the data analysis yeah
so I've been trying to design a database
that makes it easy to do that and the
goal is to give the answers back in less
than a minute and have the program be
that big
and if we could do that that would be
great right so the first thing is
there's two kinds of stuff in this world
there are photos and that's a photo
object and this is all a crap around
photo objects okay just you know there's
a lot of encoded fields and this is the
encoding of the fields these are the
spectrographic objects and the spectral
lines this is the plate all the aspecto
grams that were taken on a certain night
are inside of one plate this is a part
of the sky and that's a larger part of
the sky so called strike okay many many
many of the astronomers queries are
spatial so I had to implement and
particular database I work with doesn't
have spatial access in it so I had to
implement a spatial access method
embarrassingly other products do have
spatial access methods but they don't do
spherical very well so I probably would
have had to do the same thing and
somebody else's product those are the 20
queries so here's a typical of one of
the 20 queries find a list of moving
objects consistent with an asteroid so
what does it mean for something to be an
asteroid well it means it's moving
pretty fast and so it turns out that in
the pipeline they take five different
exposures because they have five
different spectral bands that they're
measuring and exposures are taken at
five different times because the way the
telescope works is it points up at the
sky and the earth drifts along and the
image of the object processes across the
the CCDs and actually shift the CCDs as
the image moves and they're gathering
pixels from a certain object for about a
minute and then the object goes off of
one CCD goes on to the next CCD and now
they're gathering green pixels and now
they were grouting blue pixels and now
they're gathering red pixels so they're
getting a picture of the object at a
different time
and if the objects moving when Yuri
register those frames the object going
to be a different place okay so and they
detect moving objects in that way and
here's the query that finds the moving
objects okay and it basically says show
me all of the things where the square
root of the of the velocity and this
dimension in this dimension or I'm
greater than a certain threshold and so
we did that in and and the guy who is
serious about these things says no no no
I want fast moving objects I don't want
slow moving objects slow moving objects
I'll recognize that they've moved but if
they move a lot from frame to frame I
won't think it's the same object I think
it's a different object so here is a
picture where the object was there when
we were taking the blue picture and then
we took another picture in another
picture and then it was it registered in
the red and then it registered in the
green and those show up as three
different objects in the database okay
so now what we have to do is to paw
through the database and find something
that's very elliptical in the blue and
has no other spectrum and then all of a
sudden it's very elliptical in the red
and has no other spectrum and then some
other object it's very elliptical in the
green and has no other spectrum and in
fact these things line up so the story
behind this one is that the previous
query is a query that was one of the
quarries that Alex gave me but this
query is the fast-moving guy's was
something that a guy who is a serious C
programmer said this is something you'll
never do with sequel okay and so he said
okay that's a challenge let's try to do
that because this guy's pretty serious
and he had done this and he'd wrote a
12-page tickle script and his program
ran for three days over the ASCII files
and you know and he got in fact he found
that object so we wrote that program I
know it's horrible okay and it found
three objects in 11 minutes one of the
objects was bogus we were able to you
know point to each of those objects and
look and say oh that one is is is in
fact a cosmic ray and these others who
are good okay so this is this is another
example I think that the results are
very positive and that the twenty
queries run reasonably fast this is in
fact what the query plan is was
associated with the query
okay that's another query plan which is
fine Claus boys this is a very joint
centric thing and this is the program
that sequel wrote for us which is you
know scanning over the data so sequel is
a high-level language which is doing a
lot of data planning for you okay what's
the performance
well the performance is pretty good none
of the queries take much more than a
half hour most of them run in a minute
some of them run in a second
interestingly the the CPU density of
this thing is about 10 MIT's
per i/o and million instructions per IO
and I'm sorry what is it 200
instructions oh yes
200 instruction it should really say 200
instructions per byte of i/o is what
that the thing at the bottom should say
so M dolls law is one instruction per
byte of i/o this is much more CPU
intensive and M those laws 50,000
instructions per disk i/o and so this is
a much more CPU intensive application
than the typical TPC ABC you know
transaction processing kind of thing but
the fact is that gigahertz processors
are really good at this and and in fact
you need a lot of disks to keep one of
these processors busy ok summary all the
queries run many of the queries are
needle-in-a-haystack things you just
scan through the entire database and so
the goal here is to be able to scan
through the database very fast using
Intel style computers we're going
through at about 250 megabytes a second
and the way you go through 250 megabytes
a second is on a multiprocessor you use
all the processors in parallel of course
sequel automatically parallelize your
search that's something your C program
won't do for you
and of course sequel uses the indices
that are appropriate for your search Oh
counting is very common bidding is very
common cubes are not data loading is a
nightmare the data that we get is is
dirty as we write our queries we find
bugs in the query
data and so we asked the people who run
the pipeline how come this is all zeros
or how come this thing has such huge air
bars and they say and to some extent
were the first people who are looking at
the data and because it's so hard to
look at and so having a nice query tool
is great QA but the other part of the
story is it would be nice to have better
ways of dealing with data ingest and
parallelism is big win and the sequel
looks pretty positive so sort of the
call to action all all talks are
supposed to have so what you know what
should I take away from this so if if
you do visualization I mentioned that we
have 20 database queries and 10
visualization tasks we have made zero
progress on visualization if you do
visualization help I think it's the
simple thing there's there's no buddy
doing nobody with a good visualization
agenda working on this problem as far as
I can tell if you do databases here's
some data you can practice on if you
distributed systems the whole idea of
web services and how you integrate web
services together this is again a really
great testing ground for your ideas and
if you do astronomy education here's a
great resource and just as a side
comment
astronomers are very nice people they
have this whole cooperative thing I mean
they're they're kind of weird people
they get you know they work at night and
they work alone and so on and you know
so you might think wow these people are
misanthropes and but now they're
actually a fairly pleasant and and they
they the senior faculty put the junior
faculty or the this the graduate
students name first on the papers which
is a sure sign of something good going
on and and that you know they're very
smart they know way more physics
chemistry mathematics and astronomy than
I'll ever know and they also know Unix
much better than I know and they pretty
good at Windows and it's it's awesome to
work work with them so and and as I said
the questions are cosmic so that having
hey almost on time so we have time for
questions and
but not much shrewdly do they ask oh
yeah absolutely
so okay well now I'm gonna get into
these into astronomy but another test
case was they it's painful to collect
spectra they're collecting an order of
magnitude or two more stars and galaxies
than other people have
it's mostly galaxies than other people
but they are also collecting an order of
magnitude more spectra than other people
have a million is a lot typical surveys
are thousands of spectrum not millions
okay and but spectra are hard to collect
so they would what they like to do is to
take the five colors that they get from
every object and and predict what it the
object's redshift is because one of the
main reasons for doing spectra is to
predict the redshift or calculate the
redshift of the object so they'd like to
predict the redshift from this very poor
man's spectra okay so they've been doing
that and they've got lots of spectra and
the innocent one but it turns out that
there's one class of galaxies that's
poorly characterized in the data set
they have they don't have very many
spectra for that class so they wanted to
quickly take and get 100 spectra or a
thousand spectra of that class of
galaxies with the process they have the
way their pipeline works and the way
their programs work they would have to
go and modify some horrendous program
which picks how to drill holes in a
plate and then they run fibers from
those holes to the spectrograms and so
on so the thing that sort of drives the
drilling process for the plate was a
program that nobody wanted to touch okay
so they worked for an hour and a half
and wrote a sequel query that picked the
did target selection for them this
sequel query replaced a fairly large
program that had been several months of
effort now the fact is those people had
to develop algorithms and so on and the
guys who do this program were we're had
benefit of all that but the fact is that
they you
in less than an evening they had a plate
drilling and they wouldn't have not have
done this if if they'd had to go back
and modify the program so they now have
done the drilling and the it worked
beautifully
they got 99% success rate in you know in
picking their targets and they're now
doing the data analysis and they've
increased the data set for that kind of
galaxies by several orders of magnitude
I mean I think they had like 10 and they
now have like a thousand and and it's I
mean it's it's the difference between
batch where the turnaround time is
months or years and something where the
turnaround time is from one point you
you what you have to do is minutes or
hours to do the task and then there is
maybe a follow-up observation I mean
between the time they did the drilling
plan and the time they got the spectra
back was about two and a half months and
but they now have that data and they
were able to ingest that data in about
20 minutes
in the previous scheme it would have
taken them weeks to ingest the data and
so I mean somehow the work factor is
much lower in this new scheme and I mean
that's that's the perimeter there's
nothing wrong with C and and ASCII files
it's just that it's much easier I mean
it's a Turing machine this is a Turing
machine I mean but it's like the Turing
tarpit I think is the Fred Brooks this
thing I mean yeah everything is possible
but not some things are not very easy
and the pros
[Applause]
when when you talk bad the other is one
of educating them one of them is that
when they get a dataset with the set of
software tools that are data there was
this first thing they do is they start
modifying so they know for them the
particular piece of software binary of
it is not interesting because for each
individual and each of division we will
probably want to modify it and then when
somebody else picks it up they will use
that modified version so that the
abstract in some sense the abstract
stuff that they're looking at is going
to model be modified over time
the other piece of it is that in fact
your example of the the object it's
moving with time and in a different
spectra causes one to say well okay so
there were these three five different
sets of data
now in fact that the underlying data
could be made richer by saying they're
actually all one object and there are
different ways in that way so database
people don't know what I don't think
almost like mischaracterizing database
people miss the object-oriented world
tends to say this is an object you know
it's a table and it always be a table at
you know it's a it's got a title or it's
got a you know a definition and that is
its definition forever
that's very contrary to this idea that
things fiber objects out there little
involved with time and
by the time I come back to it next time
it would be different than it was the
previous time well yeah that's that's I
was hinting at that um when I talked
about the trade-off between RPC where
you get back an object with known fields
in RPC where you get back an object
which is an XML document and it's not
just database people it's language
people okay I mean you've got no name
for that new field because it didn't
exist when you compiled the program okay
so this is the early binding late
binding discussion and it's not peculiar
to databases we already see schema
evolution in this we're actually on
version 3 of the schema and the tables
are just proliferating there's just
getting there being decorated by the
side people are adding more and more and
more things it's not just yeah yeah
right well certainly it's built in but
but and the the a style of work for
astronomers is that they go to the
archive they pull data out of the
archive they put it into their private
space and they pull data from various
archives and in fact that's the premise
I've been operating on and they have and
and from that base they then go forward
and do the kinds of modifications you've
been talking about
absolutely yes yeah so now you find
yourself wanting to publish code as well
as data yeah and I'm not there yet I
guess I'll get there real soon
you're right
as as the reason why you want to ship
but of the cultural question I meant to
clip stop complaining that the internet
basically because he became an
astronomer
so the highlight on mouthing and chilly
a look at the Stars they can no longer
justify that when you switch from
astronomy be 99% programming to 1%
program in 1997 astronomy what happens
to the culture well so I think it's
actually what's happening is subcultures
are growing there are people who are
curators of the data there are people
who are the telescope's aren't going
away there's more more pixels coming
there's going to be people it's going to
be possible to operate telescopes and in
fact to plan things but in fact the
people who go to the Keck find that when
they go up on the Mauna Kea is that the
name of it it's the air is very thin up
there and they don't think very clearly
so they actually stay down at sea level
and operate it from sea level and and
you know they have it there's this stuff
about oh well you can log on to a
telescope anywhere in the world and and
and observe but I've actually done that
and the thing you realize is well a
telescope actually takes a while to do
the exposure and then it has to process
the image and and and it's not an
interactive experience you take a
picture you wait and then five minutes
later you get the image and so I mean
there's so I think there's gonna be a
culture of people who run the telescope
okay and and decide mission planning and
and work on telescopes there's going to
be a culture of people who curate the
data and there's gonna be a culture of
people who build analysis tools and and
develop algorithms and then they're
gonna be a culture of people who who
look for trends typically and it's
possible for you to be a member of
several of these cultures but I but so I
think there there will continue to be
people who are really instrument
builders and it'll be continued to PP
people who are really astronomers and
incidentally you can be a member of
several of those cultures but the what
you do in the course of the day and each
of those is somewhat different
mentioned metadata as being an assault
call the power attack
[Applause]
well I'm struggling i how am i attacking
it bottom up I'm looking at the
astronomy data and trying to figure out
how to publish it in a way that would be
understandable and and I'm using XML XML
schemas to do today
yes yeah I am but but I mean I don't
have a better idea XML schema
[Applause]
and actually have been working well I've
been working with the Astronomy
community trying to you know say
maybe because your has explained what
you're talking about we have all these
objects that are arising on this massive
amount of day and there are a number of
characteristics that high-level
characterize that's data about data
metadata how you characterize what you
described in that metadata
language is very interesting and itself
tends to change over time and also you
know the fact that this is the Sloan
survey and it was taken by these people
so there's the provenance and you know
so you can use the Dublin core to say
okay the author of this and so there
there are things like dublin core that
you could use I'm actually yes I'm
actually working on the I'm not working
on the 400 attributes but but the simple
fact is I am saying okay everything is
in degrees and everything is in you know
there are various units about magnitude
and and megahertz or kilohertz or and
and so there are certain units like
Hertz and degrees and so on which I am
getting from standards bodies but there
is also names for things which the
astronomers have and I'm trying to take
those names and codify them and yet so
fundamentally my embarrassing problem I
face is that the data I get is already
in some schema and I'm trying to figure
out how to describe it in a common
schema and I have to confess that I'm
not aware I don't know what Merlot is
and I should go off in and dig into it
[Applause]
I think your subtitle
what are you
our lessons we're here
[Music]
maybe well I don't know much about
what's going on in genomics the
impression I get is that there C and
ASCII guys and women and that they're
not heavily into but girls yeah well so
I'm getting deeper into trouble I'm
sorry alright but but that fundamentally
they're not heavily ah yeah so they're
not heavily into the use of databases
and on Siddhant Lee I'm not sure how
relevant this is because the something
that's pivotal here is spatial query
something this pivotal there is sequence
distance and and sequence matching and I
think in the in the whole business of
doing the genome sequencing and just
managing the workflow and tracking the
work and so on I'm sure database
technology be great for that but when it
comes to a genomic database I'm I think
that what you basically have is strings
and you're the basic object is a segment
of genetic segments and the basic
operations are similarity and distance
and matching and so there's a whole
object library there and the kind of
indexing that database systems do right
now I'm not sure we'd be all that
helpful there been some research things
on that but I think it's different than
this there's similarities which is to
say lots of data but the difference is
the visual interface would be quite
different I believe that would be the
metaphor of of genetics and the
representation would in fact be
something which makes it easy to index
genetic sequences which is quite
different from the spatial and KD trees
for color cuts and things I mean so
there's a bunch of of index methods that
I'm using that probably would not be
applicable
right and the whole the whole idea of
having a set of 20 queries and saying
okay software guys go off and you know
make this good and if you can do this
well you can do a lot of things that we
want to do well and probably that basic
idea is is is quite applicable
[Applause]